And my daughter does isn't demonstrating the same enthusiasm that her older
brother does.
And you try and you try to suss out like the nature nurture question cause I
feel like I'm doing the same inputs.
Right.
But I'm getting different results.
And it leads you to wonder,
um,
you know,
it's a very small sample size.
But when I talked to other parents,
like you know,
parents who are parenting right now,
young kids,
I just keep encountering other dads who are having the same experience.
And you,
it really leaves you to wander sort of like what sort of like cultural
influences are going on there where it's like the enthusiasm oftentimes among
young girls are not as high as the enthusiasm among boys.
It's hard to unpack.
I don't know.
It's hard to unpack everything.
Yeah,
that's,
that's my question is like sage,
what's,
how old your kids while the two I'm talking about are eight and five?
Yeah.
Man,
I don't know how much culture plays a part.
I know.
I really think that it's,
and it's obviously in my small sample group and eight year old and a 10 year old
for the youngest kids,
the a,
the eight year old fucking loves it.
They're both girls.
The 10 year old,
she's like,
whatever,
you know,
if I tried to wake her up,
take her fish and she'd be like,
leave me alone.
No.
Going back to sleep.
I'm sure there are parents out there who,
you know,
I haven't met him yet.
Maybe they're out there where they have like a boy and a girl and the girls into
fire it up and the boys not maybe I haven't.
I guarantee you it's,
there's,
Jamie and I were just talking about this yesterday because I was watching this
video of these,
there's,
I want to try to put this in a respectful way.
MMM.
I think there,
I'm sure you're aware of this.
There's people that are in the hunting world,
the outdoor industry that I think are in it because it's a good avenue to get
attention.
If you're like a hot chick.
Yeah.
If you're a hot check and you,
you know,
you wear pink and you,
you go out and shoot things,
you'd take all these grip and grins with deer and like this,
you're going to get a lot of likes.
Yeah.
Because it's
Magine the,
the,
the male perspective on it.
Yeah.
It's like here's the woman who has everything.
Exactly.
And she likes to hunt.
Yeah.
She's hot and she likes to hunt.
And uh,
there's quite a few of them.
And it's,
I was telling Jamie,
it's a weird world because,
pardon me,
I don't want to be a sexist.
I don't want to look at these girls and I,
I don't,
I don't look at a guy who hunts and who wants to be a part of the outdoor
industry and go,
Oh,
this guy is just doing this because he thinks this is his avenue for fame and
success.
I think,
well,
here's a guy who really likes to hunt and he realizes there's people like Steve
Rinella and John Dudley out there and these famous hunters,
man,
I want to be a famous hunter.
How do I do it?
You know,
how do I go?
Well I'm going to just start taking Instagram pictures and say a lot of the same
shit that they say and sort of,
you know,
put myself into the cultural norm.
I don't think like that with girls.
Cause you're like,
you just want to have men like you.
Not all of them.
A lot of them I think are super legit.
A lot of them are said,
but there's unquestionably this added element in that world and it with it.
Let's be super generous and say it's only 10% of them,
but that 10% of my,
hmm.
I'm not smell a rat.
I'm not unaware of what you're talking about.
I'm sure you're not,
but I notice it.
Yeah.
I even had like a,
yeah,
I remember it was.
Yeah.
There's kind of like a,
yeah,
like a,
like a like,
like a sex pot kind of.
Yeah.
Huntress scene,
you know?
Yeah.
It's super made up.
Full war paint,
fake eyelashes.
Hot as fuck.
Skin tight clothes out there,
shooting shit,
taking pictures.
Yeah.
It's weird.
And then you go to their Instagram page and it's like there's pictures of that
and then there's a lot of pictures with their butt up in the air where they're
doing some strange exercise getting ready for both of these and yeah,
accentuating there.
But like that's weird.
I don't do any of those exercises.
I would really like to,
I don't know.
I would really like mine to,
cause I'm going to continue leaning on my,
uh,
under continue leaning out my daughter,
cause I would really like her
okay.
On keep leaning on her until I feel like she's in the,
at an age where she can legitimately say she doesn't want to go.
Right.
Because right now if I asked her every day,
hey,
you want to go to school,
she'd be having a real delinquency problem.
So you're like,
you know,
you really like,
yeah.
Uh,
you make kids do stuff.
I took her duck on a couple of weekends ago.
It was cold morning and we get out there and before it's even legal light,
she's like,
I felt terrible.
She's laying there crying Bauhaus,
colder feet are,
if my boy was doing that,
I would have a very different attitude about it.
Right.
Then when she's crying,
her crying cause she's cold,
like made me feel awful.
Right.
With my boy.
I've been like
suck it up.
But her,
I'm like,
oh man.
Yeah,
she's all cold now.
Yeah.
And then it makes it so you really,
there,
there really is a difference.
Yeah.
There's that.
There's a,
there's a difference there.
And it's not,
you know,
the people that buy a hunting license in this country,
90% of the people by hunting in a 90% are males.
Right?
Right.
So one in 10 licensed holders,
there's a woman,
but then there's,
there's more women than men in the,
you know,
slightly more men,
women than men in the country.
And there's a ton of ways of explaining it.
We talked about earlier with neanderthals or maybe the neanderthals didn't have
these like divided roles,
but in all the hunter and hunter gatherer cultures is very normal to see a
division of labor here and to have like the men were out hunting and women,
we're not,
there's a bunch of explanations for that.
Like people were tied to being home to care for small children and you know,
couldn't afford risk.
Right.
Something to,
they vary.
There are,
there's some women that go out with the hunting parties,
you know,
if it is,
the minute you say no,
someone's going to point out to some right.
Variation.
But in your experience,
you've,
you've done several of these trips to these remote jungles.
Oh yeah.
But that's just what,
that's such a small thing.
I mean,
you get,
rather than looking at personal experience,
just like from kind of exploring literature and reading about,
you know,
historic accounts and more people found out what people do,
uh,
it is very much the norm is very much the norm.
That hunting was patrilineal descent activity and all of these cultures you go
to,
you like the cult of the hunter is like a male sort of Colt,
but the factors that made it that way.
Okay.
That's sort of the,
you,
you have to assume it comes from some kind of practical factor,
right.
The factors that made it that way aren't there anymore.
Um,
and I said it's a difficult thing to unpack if it winds up being that if I have
two boys and one girl for winds up being that,
uh,
both boys become avid hunters and fishermen and somehow my daughter does not,
I'll probably view it as some bit of a personal failure though I'll never know
what really was going on.
Like I said,
it's hard.
It's hard to like unloaded.
I wish I could have 100 children,
like 50 girls and 50 boys and have a bigger samples.